che cazzo funziona
ma.nav a questo e quello vecchio sono
scemo neanche trovare i giochi funziona
santo iddio me ne frega un cazzo di
naruto online ci siamo tutti ragazzi e
venire da quest'anno video sono affari j
line up che chi sta parlando di un mite
stanley di una tragica stone a era
l'altro giorno ma [ __ ] ed oggi
siamo su what your bones due hanno fatto
il 2 scommetto il primo è raro mi
ricordo stato il primo vacche che ho
fatto pero sicuramente uno dei
primissimi and what your bones 2 scavo
che il boss due fantasie edition
ci sono altri dieci modi per uccidere il
boss che prima non c'erano in modo
fantasy adesso non so che cosa consigli
perché facciano unicorno cassetto ma che
cazzo
va bene e questo sarebbe fantastica se
ascoltate una bomba cos'è no vabbè
bellissimo e va bene con quale grafica
in hd tra l'altro sono diventato
superman
va bene qua già ovviamente quando uccidi
il boss c'è sempre quello che poi va a
pulire che poi non so effettivamente
dopo non nucleare che cazzo devi pulire
la mano con la mano no vabbè non ci sto
tenendo va bene perché questa cosa mi fa
ridere invece di farmi schifo qual è il
problema ma una mega bistecca cos'è sta
roba cleaner non è roba per vegani zio
guarda che non ci sta in un sacco solo è
quello che fino adesso è stato
abbastanza soddisfacente però devo
vedere ancora che cosa significa fantasy
è solo un po più cruento per adesso il
destino c'è un [ __ ] unicorno dentro
cestino perché ha paura degli unicorni
concedente di male a parte incornare i
muri vabbè ma quello è lo faccio anche
io quando devo prendere i quadri
ma cosa cazzo sto guardando ma veramente
ma cos'è sta roba è la cosa più trash
che abbia mai visto
la musichetta era stupendo faccio
cleaner voglio vedere che cosa pulisce
il tizio e cosa cazzo pulisciti è
passato un unicorno ha incornato il mio
capo se un unicorno nel cestino va bene
è curioso che l'unicorno esca dal
cestino e non dal disegno prove facciamo
sportello che era quanto violento mi
ricordo che fosse scansionando l'ultima
volta ragazzi è stato fiori alla madonna
che c'erano raggi potenti
dio mio a e chiude continua va bene non
era ancora filo scusate mi sono
sbagliato quattro su dieci ragazzi c'è
una più trash dell'altra prova bensì
come fantasy sono curioso di vedere le
altre sei d'orologio e il cassetto 18 è
appena uscito saltato dal cassetto ha
risucchiato negato
certo
sono tutti
quali sono tutti altri con il sullo
sfondo sono altri capi questa roba che
se succede quali sono haters laimer
vorrei a pulire che l'ha portato
all'inferno oddio la casa dell'acqua a
[ __ ] che calcio forte in faccia
no non la vetere nel culo ti prego meno
male poteva andargli molto peggio
ho trovato il modo di ingrassare ragazzi
funziona credo però non ci tengo
tantissimo livello ragazze che su flickr
o cleaner arriverà al tizio con i sacchi
di immondizia che cazzo ci fai quei
sacchi di immondizia con tutto il paese
le scarpe no sotto lo zerbino ma non
c'erano capire
ok si è creato uno zerbino è con te mi è
conteso ridotto no vabbè bellissima
bellissima questa era la più bella che
lo sta facendo ha già questa qui è stato
fatto menarin vi prego fate mela
rivedere tra tutte le uccisioni tutti
quanti wac questa è la più bella in
assoluto bellissima questo è il
criminale
è un po violenta e prove alla mano l'ho
già fanno l'altra mano
l'altra mano età di 16 anni
cos'è divise le acque blu o altro
posso anche tagliare la bistecca così
ragazzi ne mancano due ma non sto
capendo quali sono già aspettarti
l'orologio perché io devo sempre a riva
che poi sono dieci e noi che soltanto
quindi dovrei trovarla telefono anche
sportellata forte apostolo 38 lato no
mica peso lo facesse roteare non sarebbe
stato un po meglio o meno violento
comunque fantasy un cazzo cioè horror
prove ne tornino grazie
gentilissimo mi fai anche i compiti non
lo trova oddio un caso e il soffitto lui
l'ho trovata ragazzi ma anche al
soffitto superman l'ha già fatto quindi
non può essere come minimo casca
qualcosa dal soffitto a noi gesù e gesù
cos'è sta roba
va bene
[Musica]
poetico lui rimasto con lo sguardo in
alto e non si è mosso di un millimetro
affrontare c'è più in grazie con la
musica di prima dell'arma cos'è ma cos'è
non le posso mettere queste cose c'è dio
che ti sarà che curò tanto succederà
qualcosa di peggio sul convinto
[Musica]
no vabbè che finale belli dava ai
ragazzi il più corto di tutti il piu
corte in assoluto ma il più bello il
finale geniale fantastico c'è la fine
finito lui a fare il dipendente ciò vuol
dire che adesso sono io che me la prendo
nel culo play again no grazie va bene
sono contento così non ho detto non
grazie ho detto no grazie
no no no no no va bene così grazie mille
sapere ragazzi li ho fatto anche la
faccia se ti sciogli sta roba che era un
santo iddio quante robe fanno di cuochi
jormin chiave ormai siamo abituati tanto
quindi ora figo però veramente figo
spero che video vi sia piaciuto mi sto
in trippando per è perché mi ha mandato
in parco europa di satana non mi piace
assoluto per il miglior waka attualmente
si stenda vabè fighissima 48 detto
quanto è figo fighissimo in questo video
satirici vediamo fossero video per
ragazzi